hey what's up guys it's Marquez from the
mkbhd Channel and today we're gonna be
taking a look at the brand new Twitter
design for a bunch of new platforms
including desktop mobile Android and
iPhone so also if you want to follow me
on twitter i'm at mkbhd on twitter so
that link is in the description below so
that any further ado let's take a look
we'll start with the desktop version
courtesy of a video Twitter release
today so start off with just a timeline
as you can see here it looks pretty
similar to the old Twitter with you know
inline photos and videos and everything
which is nice
then it zooms out even more and it's
looking a lot more like that new
Facebook Timeline a two-column layout
it's kind of an activity feed it's
actually really nice looking it I don't
know if you leave a comment what do you
guys think of this but I think it looks
really good you also have that composed
window and some information about
yourself about the top and then you have
this brand new discover page and I think
this is really the biggest change of the
new Twitter it categorizes the people
you tweet and lets you discover things
based on hashtags and you can see it's
really freaking cool there's a lot new
more image content a whole bunch of
videos built in it really looks nice and
I think it's a bit more visually
pleasing experience and I love this this
right here the the view video button I
really hope it keeps this way for all
YouTube videos so when I tweet out my
new videos you guys will be able to
watch it right on Twitter of course you
want to comment on it on YouTube but
still I really like this button but
anyway back up to the top there's a
connect tab and this is basically the
exact same thing as the activity tab I
showed you before this guy's Mouse was
really slow but yeah this is the same
thing as the activity tab so without any
further ado let's go ahead and take a
look the other platforms so start off by
taking a look at it on my G Motorola
Droid just so you can be pretty sure
that this app will work on just draw any
other phone in existence but honestly
this app looks a lot better than I
thought it would I wasn't a big fan of
the old version but you can see it's
laid out nicely here and incorporates
all the same features of the website
except for brand pages which were also
launched today but that's not a huge
deal to me anyway
but this does actually looks really good
it's pretty elegant I'm really excited
to use this on having my future Galaxy
Nexus as I am with a lot of other things
with a big screen and plenty of room to
compose and do all sorts of things so
Twitter looks really nice on mobile
on the phone now they did make one
mistake and they forgot to optimize a
version again for honeycomb or tablet
versions so there's still no Android
tablet version as you can see it looks a
little bit clunky here so we can stick
with the phone version honestly it's not
too bad I'm not gonna switch to it yet I
still use another client called Tweaker
which is pretty much the most badass
thing out there it's really fast and
really clean but complements the Twitter
on the redesign of the new mobile
Android app all the iPhone equivalents
have you seen on the side look very
similar to the Android app so there you
go guys let me know what you guys think
about this in the comments I know not
all of you are on Twitter but I know
those of you who are on Twitter who have
been using it for a while will find that
this is the first major update Twitter's
rolled out in a long long long long time
so let me know what you think and I'll
talk to you guys in the next video
thanks for watching peace